Dwyane Wade was apparently left on red
by a fan he facebooked messaged back in
2009 but how do we know if it was really
him the fan did screenshot the message
from Facebook and post it but I know
what you're thinking this is probably
fake and it's a regular troll message
especially when you find out what the
post even said in the message Dwayne
thanked the fan for their kind comments
on his page and he said that he was in
fact real and that people thought his
page was fake but just like anyone else
at the time he was just trying to learn
social media and get up to speed but it
gets crazier D Wade saw the message
going viral recently and he commented on
the Instagram saying I can't confirm nor
deny but it's giving me this is probably
real